you know how many of you here have
opinions about AI yet you've never spent
50 hours really using it if you can fall
in love with the concept of maybe when
faced with somebody telling you
something you've never heard about
before you will have a much greater
chance to get out of the world what you
want
one of the things that are needed to be
successful in life there's a lot of
things that come to mind a lot of what I
think about is self-esteem and genuinely
being in a good place with yourself
because you won't put yourself out there
at the level you need to if you're
insecure
and so I think a lot about self-esteem
and self-love and a lot of other stuff
but the word that I want to talk about
is the word curiosity
I think everybody here
can probably sense
that this web 3.0 last year we we
defined web 3.0 as crypto and nfts
but I I challenge that concept and I say
let's take a step back and realize web
3.0 probably encompasses a lot more
things for me personally it encompasses
AR for me personally it even encompasses
something that's been around for a long
time like QR codes because I think it's
in functionality in pipes that matters
for everyone here it definitely involves
ZR and we know that
and it clearly involves AI which is
going to be such a big deal we me
included were very stuck in what we're
doing right now
meanwhile this is probably the biggest
era of change coming up since the
invention of the iPhone accelerated
social media in a profound way I have a
feeling that a lot of people here
you're not sure exactly every aspect of
it none of us are but I have a feeling
everybody can feel here that the next 20
years she's gonna look a little bit
different that between Ai and AR and VR
and decentralized servers like it just
feels like it's not the status quo that
the last 15 years are
if that will be some of the biggest
opportunities that you will ever see in
your entire life in 1997 and 1998 every
internet company that went public was
worth a billion dollars with zero
Revenue all of those stocks collapsed
but it didn't mean that the internet was
not going to be one of the biggest
inventions of our time
that's just blockchain that's not even
mentioning what's going on in Ai and in
the last year
everybody here has been affected and
Blown Away
by Jasper mid-journey or chat GPT all of
us have tasted real AI not fake AI like
we were for the last seven years
and it really caught everyone's
attention
these things are going to converge
together
at scale
and so I asked all of you please do not
leave this conference
without asking yourself how curious are
you
you know how many of you here have
opinions about AI yet you've never spent
50 hours really using it
you know many people here have opinions
about everything that's going on in new
technology yeah it's because your friend
told you or you read two articles you
didn't have the Curiosity to go all in
you lead with no sometimes you lead with
yes but very few lead with maybe
if you leave with anything from this
talk given how young this audience is if
you can fall in love with the concept of
maybe
when faced with somebody telling you
something you've never heard about
before or something new in your journey
which will be consistent for the rest of
our lives with technology if you meet
that new genre that new platform that
new technology with the concept of maybe
you will have a much greater chance to
get out of the world what you want and
so I argue at scale that one of the
biggest things to lean into within your
own body
going into the next decade is finding
out for yourself with yourself where do
you sit with curiosity are you a curious
person or are you not and how do you
develop more curiosity for me the way I
built more curiosity was I started
surrounding myself with people that were
more curious
and so I challenge you to really think
about this because it will really matter
foreign